Terra is with us in Lexington Kentucky
hi Tara how are you hi I'm well thank
you so much for taking my call
sure what's up so basically long story
short and my husband and I both kind of
came from a real situation growing up
and so we decided we were going to do
everything right we went to college we
bought a house you know all this stuff
and now basically we found ourselves in
a position where we make decent money
but even something as simple as like
getting the oil things in the car you
know is stressful just because you know
our income is just maxed out completely
we just have so much debt and we just
don't know where to start
okay and so what is your household
income and we make a lot around ninety
thousand a year
okay and what what kind of debt do you
have not counting your house so the
worst thing we didn't make very smart
decisions in college and so we have
about $100,000 between the two of us in
student loan debt we have a little over
$60,000 in cars and we're upside down on
both cars so we're not really sure how
we would even go about selling them to
get out from under room we've got about
ten thousand dollars in credit cards
we've got a ten thousand dollar personal
loan
we've got some medical bills just a
little bit of everything really
so about $200,000 in debt not counting
your house pretty close to that yeah and
what are you alone at home and we owe
about a hundred and twenty eight
thousand right now so it's not the
problem well what you did was you came
out of school and acted like there was
no how long have y'all been out of
school well we myself I've been out for
I guess it's about six years and then my
husband and he worked full-time through
the whole time I won lots lowers and he
actually just graduated a couple years
ago yeah but from college age you guys
are seven years out you fit the pattern
because basically you just
anything you wanted to buy and didn't
think about the consequences until you
added it all up and can't breathe
exactly education cars things on credit
cards whatever we just put it on you
know let's just go get it as long as I
can sign a piece of paper and walk out
with the item I'm good
let's go so so that the question then
comes is this I I've worked with folks
in your situation and I've been in
Dumber situations and deeper situations
than you're in I've done Dumber things
and you've done but the you know what I
found is that when you wake up in this
situation the people who are able to
change their lives make dramatic moves
because they are truly sick and tired of
being sick and tired is that you guys
yes I mean it's just we should not feel
the way we feel every day it is so
stressed and and we're just surviving
basically okay so here's what we're
gonna do we're gonna sell both cars
we're gonna cut up your credit cards
you're not going to go inside a
restaurant for the next three years and
you're not going on vacation
oh I'm not kidding I'm dead serious yeah
you're broke you're on the verge of
bankruptcy and if you do not get radical
you're gonna see the bankruptcy court I
mean these cars are freaking insanity
absolute insanity that you own $60,000
worth of car debt and you make 90 I mean
the Finance Manager must have been
smoking crack who makes this loan you
didn't qualify for that that's awful
it's a disaster and you're sitting there
with $100,000 and student loan debt and
then you go do that
oh my gosh yeah two beaters you get to
$1,000 cars and we get rid of these
things so who do you owe the money to on
these two stupid automobiles one of them
is US bank and then the other one is a
credit union perfect that's good news
and so the worst part of that is that
also tells me you have a fairly high
interest rate on both of them don't you
well I think it's not terrible and I
think whatever limits around 5% and the
other one it may be like six or so maybe
not as bad as I thought that was wrong
okay well here's what you do you go to
the
branch of US bank you go to your credit
union you sit down and purr in person
both of you and you talk to them about
the fact that you are on the verge of
bankruptcy and that you don't want to
file bankruptcy and we want to get out
of this but we want to turn this around
before we get past the lip and can't get
back in the bowl okay and so you guys
here's the deal we're gonna sell these
cars and you're gonna you're talking to
your branch manager now and you're gonna
allow us to sign a note for the
difference for the amount that's upside
down and and then you put the car up for
sale you don't panic and give it away
you don't let it be repo'd and you don't
you don't sell it to a dealer at
wholesale you put it on Craigslist and
get the most out of it you can get
because whatever you don't get you're
gonna have to pay back in a debt Wow
and so get on Kelly Blue Book kbb.com
put those cars in there with your
husband tonight when he gets home and
figure out what you can sell them for
private sale and get rid of them and
sign a note for the difference you're
gonna have to do a little negotiating a
little talking a little persuading with
this bank and this credit union but they
are already unsecured on that portion of
the debt so they might as well let you
sign an unsecured personal note for that
portion of the debt even if they bump
the interest rate up a little bit I
don't care I want rid of these
ridiculous automobiles and then you guys
go get you a thousand dollar car to get
back and forth to work that's all you
need for right now we're not gonna drive
a beater the rest of our life but for
right now you're driving a beater and
you're looking for extra jobs and
anything you can do to get your income
up what are you own that you could sell
well it's not like we owe on everything
that we have pretty much maybe there's
anything as far as let's have a garage
sale this weekend let's put the cat on
Craig's List the dog on eBay and let's
try to get some stuff moving into money
and then any extra work you guys can
pick up anywhere to add to the income
and then we cut the credit cards up if
you can put the student loans
temporarily on a hardship deferral that
would be fine if not that's made the
very minimum and then I want you to get
on a tight budget no eating out no
vacations we're complete
scorched earth on the deal here so and
if we take 200,000 and we pay 50,000 for
four years mm-hmm you're debt-free if
you sell the cars you can probably do it
in about three okay but you're gonna
have no life for three years so that you
have a great life after that right but
the problem is that you can wander into
debt you can't wander out you have to
get wired up fired up and go crazy like
I'm talking about here this scorched
earth mindset this okay and that's what
gets you out that's what gets you out if
you're willing to walk through that I'll
show you how to do it the nine week
class we have is called Financial Peace
University I will pay for you to go if
you and your husband will promise to
both attend that I'm gonna put you on
hold Kelly's gonna pick up if you make
her that promise she'll put you in the
class if you don't then you're gonna
wander along until you figure out that
you're gonna have to get serious about
this this is the Dave Ramsey show hey
guys thanks for watching if you enjoyed
this video click the subscribe button to
get the latest content and check out
these other great clips from the show
you
[Applause]
[Music]